y la economía turca también se está
viendo afectada por los terremotos no es
así Jorge Hurtado Buenas noches buenas
noches María Clara Así es bueno la bolsa
de Estambul suspendió la negociación en
sus mercados de acciones y derivados a
los pocos minutos de la apertura hoy y
después de una caída del principal
índice en un 7% este índice de
referencia del país que se conoce como
el X u 100 cayó hasta un 16% desde su
cierre el viernes antes de que se
cancelaran las operaciones el miércoles
el comunicado oficial dice que debido al
aumento de la volatilidad de los
extraordinarios movimientos de precios
tras la catástrofe del terremoto y con
el fin de garantizar el funcionamiento
transparente eficiente estable justo y
competitivo de los mercados se decidió
cerrar la capitalización bursátil del
índice msci cayó de 39.700 millones de
dólares a finales de la semana pasada a
unos 35.800 millones de dólares al
cierre del los inversores locales
representan allí el 70% de la
participación de bursátiles frente al 35
que eran en 2020 pero muchos inversores
internacionales se han ido en los
últimos años debido a las recurrentes
turbulencias del mercado y la adopción
de políticas económicas y monetarias
poco ortodoxas en ese país pero así como
los terremotos han afectado la economía
turca la guerra tiene en recesión a
Rusia sin embargo este país afirma que
este año saldrá de este impacto
económico no bueno bastante optimistas
las autoridades rusas en 2020 el pib
ruso cayó un 2,5% según los datos
oficiales del presidente de Rusia el
Ministerio de desarrollo económico de
Rusia calculó en su última previsión
macroeconómica una caída del 0,8% del
pib para este año y que volvería a
crecer en torno a un 2,6 en 2024 y 2025
pero el fmi en cambio mejoró
considerablemente en enero su
perspectiva de crecimiento de Rusia al
afirmar que la economía caerá
0,3% en 2023 2,6 puntos menos de lo
previsto inicialmente El Banco Central
de Rusia va a revisar sus previsiones
macroeconómicas para el año este viernes
pero todo apunta a que mejorará sus
estimaciones Jorge cambiemos de tema
porque las huelgas contra la Reforma
pensional en Francia por primera vez
tienen
un me tiene que ver con el sector del
petróleo bueno según los sindicatos en
las huelgas hubo cuatrocientas mil
personas en París para un total de 2
millones de manifestantes en toda
Francia durante esta tercera jornada los
trabajadores de total energys reanudaron
el miércoles por la mañana su huelga Es
la primera vez que la huelga se amplía a
la suspensión de envíos de combustible
de las refinerías a los depósitos según
Eric selling coordinador del sindicato
en este grupo del total energys los
sindicatos y la oposición exigen La
retirada del aumento de la edad de
jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años a
partir de ahora hasta el año 2030 Este
es el punto central de la Reforma de
pensiones que impulsa el presidente
Emmanuel macrón una mayoría amplia de
franceses rechaza esta reforma pero el
gobierno continúa con sus planes pese a
la presión social y pasamos a Chile
porque allí los precios continúan al
alza qué está pasando bueno el índice de
precios al consumidor de chile registró
en enero Un aumento intermensual del
0,8% y un crecimiento del
12,3% a 12 meses entre las divisiones
con incrementos en sus precios
destacaron alimentos y bebidas no
alcohólicas con el 1% también aumentaron
las medidas alcohólicas y tabaco un dos
coma siete por ciento pero los productos
que más subieron fueron los uniformes
escolares son 17% el vino un 6,3% la
gasolina 3,1 y el pan tos como ocho por
ciento chile cerró 2021 con una
inflación del 7,2%, la más alta en 14
años lo que llevó al Banco Central a
tomar medidas inéditas y retirar también
el estímulo monetario que aplicó durante
el inicio de la pandemia una situación
que están viviendo muchos países del
mundo en general por la inflación
generalizada pero que se suma a las
presiones internas por los cambios
políticos que existen en ese país y
además de una inflación mundial También
está afectando particularmente América
Latina y el Caribe Y a eso se suma que
en 2023 habrá un mercado laboral
complejo en la región según lo dijo hoy
la organización Internacional del
trabajo esto por múltiples crisis que
impactan los mercados de trabajo la
organización detalló que la tasa de
desocupación se redujo en 2022 a 7,2%
una cifra significativamente menor que
la de 2019 cuando registró un nivel del
8% el organismo afirma que la baja en el
desempleo es una noticia positiva en
Especial Tras la crisis de grandes
dimensiones que provocó la pandemia pero
también dijo que este año esos progresos
podrían estancarse el panorama laboral
destaca que la región es afectada por la
conjunción de múltiples crisis a nivel
global como la persistencia de la
pandemia y también la guerra en Ucrania
el informe revela que la tasa de
informalidad regional ya llegó al 50%
como era justo antes de la pandemia
Aunque en algunos países el dato es
mucho mayor Gracias Jorge por toda la
información económica volvemos dentro de
una hora con más y por ahora vayamos con
el debate presentado por Santiago López
[Música]